terre Amérique Indiana Hawkins une
communauté patriotique croissante et un brillant
exemple du rêve américain aujourd'hui
Hawkins franchit une nouvelle étape dans l'
avenir avec le tout nouveau centre commercial star court les
familles les amis et bien sûr les
adolescents peuvent se réunir pour faire du shopping
et profiter
de la vente au détail  des options pour chaque membre de
la famille, y compris le mur Walden et
Sam Goody Star Court, et
n'oubliez pas une aire de restauration ultramoderne
, c'est juste un escalator
avec l'endroit préféré de l'Amérique pour se
rafraîchir.  magasin de crème glacée entier
[Musique]
ahoy
star court ball est l'un des meilleurs
centres commerciaux d'Amérique et d'ailleurs,
alors venez et rappelez-vous que le
centre commercial star court a tout pour plaire star Court est une
filiale entièrement américaine des industries star Kord
et de l'entreprise internationale
vous